john key
[Musique]
la première entrevue qu'on a réalisé
ensemble c'était il ya vingt ans au
motel qu'a pris pour ce magnifique
disque bon car le travail dans un clip
vidéo faut pas être là jérôme était
peut-être à l'université ou au carré
saint louis on sait pas trop est ce que
vous êtes un peu nostalgique de cette
époque là au début de notre carrière on
a cherché un peu c'était qu'il est blanc
on le dit on appris de métier de façon
autonome
seul ensemble puis au fil des années ça
c'est vraiment placer cet équilibre et
je dirais cette relation
d'interdépendance écoute pour des abris
des fois je veux je m'en charge envers
par mes collègues de ne pas m'avoir dit
chan a enlevé le pince nez
[Musique]
non non
inventer album vocal sur la table quand
bref un gars
du servait seul on est heureux
en mai
une idée repenti nouvel album pour
s'asseoir avec un business vous dites
que vous êtes encore ben content de
faire la route de lège aussi même ça
fait cent fois qu'on l'a fait après 25
ans de carrière
vraiment vous vous aimez ça encore faire
la randonnée
on a vraiment beaucoup de plaisir à ça
on est contentes sur voir pitt il veut
pas dans nos villes jérôme est occupé
jeff et occuper les enfants la famille
tous savent donc quand on se voit la fin
de semaine le vendredi le samedi bon ben
on décompresse comme comme neige une
game de hockey ou une partie de 10go
crise et on est tous contents de se
revoir on aime faire des spectacles sont
donc ce cas des petits désagréments des
fois ce soit quant à 15 heures de route
à faible taux rendent à sept-îles bon
c'est peut-être des fois on s'en
passerait il est repris en avion au lieu
de le faire par la route mais reste que
le plaisir toujours renouvelé une fois
qu'on arrive
dans la ville en question un spectacle
je pense à tout ce que j'ai manqué avec
mimi
et après la chanson l'amérique l'heure
il ya le film l'amérique lançait 80
minutes de vos plus grands succès
tournée un peu partout au québec pendant
la pandémie
pourquoi avoir fait un film mais en fait
c'est une idée de longue date qui
provient de notre g ral c'est venu comme
solides et puis le fait que je demande
tout est arrêté puis nous on est en
stand by me ça nous a permis de réaliser
ce film qui est moi je suis vraiment
content de la qualité la qualité de
l'image si on parle vraiment dans un
film c'est de la qualité du cinéma
duberger ton job
si piteux
de trois jours maximum mais c'est ce
qu'on est parti si dans ce film là avec
un titre
une volonté qui était de donner donner
un sens à ces pièces là il donne un sens
à cette amérique qui pleure donc dans
toute sa beauté mais aussi ses côtés
plus dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même extraordinaire les
cowboys fringants va en plus des salles
de 5000 places en europe sur certaines
vidéos sur internet
on vous voit au zénith et carl s'essuie
les visages on dirait que vous y croyez
pas ce qu'il va en bout parce qu'on
vient de se lever
on reste alors du québec quand on voit
la voix je sais pas si c'est une des
recettes ont suggéré à tout le monde
mais non 8h du matin 7 heures quand on
monte sur scène ont fait des concessions
[Musique]
oui oh oui c'est difficile à croire je
suis mon il faut on avait joué je pense
qu'il ya lieu exact ni 8910 mais c'est
ça les cowboys sait on avait reçu une
demande s'est tue toute la vertu ou le
gouvernement et sa blonde en mariage
j'avais dit oui pour nous et latinos ont
débarqué on est des québécois par
rapport au début ce sont justement des
salons d'un mariage sur la scène devant
8000 personnes écoutent puis le gagnant
salon dommage a dit oui c'est la folie
de type 1 2 5 fois sur dix
sans une fois sauvé ses arguments mais
maintenant je vois la pierre pour voulu
monter ça fait une aventure d'un
spectacle qui fait différent pour nous
c'est parce qu'il faut comprendre que
quand tu fais un mets ton sang chaud par
année mais tu fais souvent les mêmes
chansons puis et des chansons ça fait 25
ans qu'on fait 100 fois par année donc
nous aussi il faut se divertir
différemment pour apporter du nouveau à
chaque spectacle pour qu'on rit encore
pour qu'on ait du plaisir ensemble puis
c'est ce qu'ont réussi à faire quasiment
chaque sou les cowboys fringants bon
retour sur scène on l'espère très bien
merci merci à vous c'est à tout le monde
anyway je suis content que tu reviens
dari
d'un blanc talent
[Musique]